yo creo que a todos nos llamó la
atención ese enfrentamiento entre españa
y alemania en el grupo y evidentemente
son dos selecciones que han tenido un
trabajo tanto de proyectos como una idea
de juego muy específica queremos ver
cómo este equipo de luis enrique va a
salir a afrontar esta copa del mundo
después de una interesante
clasificatoria el mundial y de una
eurocopa que empezó a demostrar que es
un equipo que quiere jugar con la pelota
y usted ya lo mencionaba pedri que
esperamos verlo funcionando con toda
esta selección evidentemente alemania
con flick y todo este proyecto que viene
trabajando después de muchos años creo
que vamos a ver los frutos pero yo creo
que los grupos donde está mayor
competencia es el de brasil y uruguay el
de brasil con suiza suiza un equipo que
está va a defenderse muy bien un equipo
aplicado tácticamente serbia con una
gran historia futbolística jamás
vlahovic una de las grandes revelaciones
del fútbol internacional en este momento
y camerún que si bien quedó eliminado la
copa africana de naciones demostró que
es un equipo competitivo igual le pasó a
uruguay que se enfrenta a portugal este
portugal de fernando saltos que no
termina de convencer desde la idea del
juego en general pero que tiene una gran
generación de futbolistas además de
contar con el cristiano ronaldo
evidentemente gana un equipo competitivo
y por supuesto corea del sur que también
trae un proyecto desde este mundial del
2002 y grandes jugadores y que ponen
siempre gracias a sus condiciones
físicas en complicaciones a los rivales
pero yo hablaría también del grupo a el
grupo de qatar un equipo que viene
trabajando muy bien con félix sánchez es
el local y evidentemente tiene todo
digamos una estructura montada desde
hace muchos años hace 12 cuando él se
entrega en el mundial a este país se de
países bajos en una reconstrucción con
louis van gaal que hoy anunció que sufre
de cáncer vamos a ver de acá a diciembre
si esto genera alguna modificación en lo
que viene siendo la planificación de
este equipo senegal campeón africano que
además cuenta con un radio maneje como
uno de los grandes referentes del fútbol
mundial y ecuador una de estas fichas
que tenemos en esta copa del mundo un
equipo que ha aprovechado ese vídeo tipo
esa fortaleza física con un técnico
bastante pragmático y sobre todo una
estructura muy importante basado en lo
que está haciendo independiente del
valle y una gran estructura de la
federación ecuatoriana estas bandas
ecuatoriana están peligrosas y sin juego
físico hablamos de ecuador de uruguay
profundizamos en el caso de brasil y de
argentina que vienen con cifras récord
en unas eliminatorias que han sido
buenas y dos grandes dominadores pueden
brasil argentina volverá a acabar con el
2 minero peores mundiales yo creo que si
juan esas son mis dos fichas en el
mundial y son mis dos fichas porque
evidentemente estos son proyectos
estructurados y han sido basados tiene
su idea basada en competir a nivel
europeo yo creo que dominaron la
eliminatoria justamente porque van más
allá de toda esta complejidad de la
planificación que significa
logísticamente venir a competir en
sudamérica desde el punto de vista de
tite un equipo muy basado en el juego de
posición que si bien no es vistoso ante
los ojos no digamos no depende tanto del
balón si ha logrado potenciar esos
grandes talentos y son equipos que no
giran en torno a sus figuras neymar y
messi en el caso de la selección de
argentina sino que son estructuras muy
sólidas desde desde el punto de vista
táctico y que en el último tercio de la
cancha permiten que sus jugadores que
son más talentosos tengan esa
creatividad sudamericana que logra
competir en el caso de scaloni fue un
técnico muy joven que llegue empezó a
demostrar que a través de una idea muy
sólida de juego lo mismo que no tienen
que pasar todos los balones por messi
pero que si se crea una estructura muy
sólida y que a potencia jugadores como
the pool este es un equipo que depende
mucho del mediocampo por ejemplo
tagliafico etcétera pero que si buscan
ser competitivos a nivel europeo yo creo
que son equipos que técnicamente pueden
resolver estos partidos y luego desde el
punto de vista de lo que llamamos la
carpeta la creatividad pueden también
resuelven tos sí creo que después de 20
años después de que acá fue levantar la
copa del mundo en el 2002 podemos tener
la esperanza de que la copa vuelva a
sudamérica